also today in Pennsylvania the president
reminded the country that his position
on securing the southern border has not
changed one bit
take a look the wall has been something
that I have been very consistent on
always as you know with reaction he is
the co-host of the five in the host of
waters world it's his world we live in
it you know let me do how do you do it
you did it ro busted up my knuckles you
know hitting the heavy bag alright Jesse
Watters and Fox News contributor Jessica
Tarlov is with us know she's got it all
wrong this is Hannah B's world just a
few months just give us a little space
alright
we're really talking about political
footballs using the dreamers here this
is one month extending and the demo
everything we want we don't have control
of the House or Senate or we're going to
shut down the government shouldn't they
be able to get the votes on their own
okay
5149 is not exactly the big comfortable
margin that you would want so a majority
okay so the point is they're using no as
a political football because they can't
get what they want
if the democrats are want to run on the
side of illegal aliens that's fine let
them run on it will run on the side of
american citizens
i think you guys don't want to die on
that hill it's not smart politics and
the hard men and working people of this
country aren't going to buy the majority
of americans Republicans and Democrats
independents as well don't see these
dreamers as illegal aliens expensive the
US military well I don't think that's
what we the decision that we need to
make here that's how people have set it
up as a juxtaposition
but that isn't what's going on here
Democrats don't want to continue punting
this down though excuse me they don't
want to drift and how do we get the
children that are in their 20s and 30
but also they want
chain migration to continue and they
want their families to be able to come
that's what they were asking they want
Uncle Leo and aunt Neddy
and the deal is they don't want the wall
you know why because walls work no that
is that's why they don't want it because
you guys need new voters as general
Kelley said last night with Bret Baier
when President Trump made that promise
he was uninformed he has evolved on the
issue it used to be one solid one grand
that's where the alligators are gonna be
all right and that's gonna take care of
it who said the alligator of the Momoa
President Barack Obama yeah on the wall
by the way well that's the thing five
years ago every major Democrat sounded
like Donald Trump today five years ago
they wanted to build the wall now it's
racist and horrible and weird killing
the children what is a Waikiki how do
you get away with that a pock recei not
you Schumer and all the rest of Durban
crying shocked you min don't call him
that
turban Durbin or dicky Durbin or
whatever people are saying what are you
calling him media I plug every night on
his program though take it back
Democrats centrist Democrats have been
consistent on this Hillary Joe Biden is
hey Dianne Feinstein have all spoken up
for border security it's part of the
game they wanted 700 plus miles of walls
five years ago things are different now
and when you say they use the language
they didn't you know what's different
American people are crossing over the
border
deputies in California that's what's tip
that outflow of immigrants from the
southern border out of this country you
can't deny it those are the numbers so
people are crossing right now because
the Border Patrol catches a thousand
people crossing each day I'm saying that
a lot of people total numbers are a net
outflow the problem is not nearly a
severe and due process a lot of pretty
severe if you're talking a thousand did
I just say something yes i sat through a
security briefing with Governor Rick
Perry
I've been down on the border 12 times
Rio Grande San Diego drug warehouses
helicopter horseback all-terrain
vehicles boats
you name it I was there went with them
also sort tunnels I was in the tunnels
that were dug and the amount of drugs is
insane but more importantly when I sat
through the security briefing six
hundred and forty two thousand Texans
were victims of crimes by illegal
immigrants in a seven and a half year
period of time wait a minute do you care
about them yeah of course I do and we
talked about Kate what am I please why
don't you protect the American people
first and as President Trump said we'll
put a door inside the wall I know the
gold door you know 40 mm yeah no Jessica
the point is is that walls work you
don't want it because you guys need
nature
they're bringing guns they're bringing
drugs some of them are good people
why are there Texas GOP representatives
that say that they don't want the border
wall it's not the most effective
infrastructure project the Democrats
don't want to spend money on because
who's gonna pay for it brilliant line no
one in his world we're living in it that
would look good like world I don't have
a world that's true nine to ten you got
that waters my world you can have it
alright thank you both thank you I don't
care if the government shuts down by the
way because all essential employees work
yeah everyone's gonna get their checks
the military keeps working you know and
all those people that get a free
vacation will end up paying them back
pay
like we always do